veamos si podemos encontrar el límite
cuando teta atiende a menos pi cuartos
de uno más la raíz de dos por el seno de
teta entre el coseno de dos tetas y como
siempre traten de darse la oportunidad
antes de que lo hagamos juntos bien solo
digamos que esto va a ser lo mismo que
el límite cuando theta tiende a menos pi
cuartos de uno más la raíz de dos por el
seno de teta entre el límite cuando teta
atiende a menos pi cuartos del concepto
de dos teta y ahora puedes ver que ambas
expresiones si fueran definiciones de
funciones o si tuviéramos que graficar
el de igualdad uno más la raíz de dos
por el seno de teta oye igual algo se 92
teta obtendríamos funciones continuas
especialmente ente está igual a menos pi
cuartos así que podríamos simplemente
sustituir y decir que esto va a ser
igual a la expresión evaluada en menos
pi cuartos
entonces me quedaría uno más la raíz de
dos por el seno de menos pi cuartos
todo esto dividido entre el coseno de
dos veces menos pi cuartos ahora bien el
seno de menos pi cuartos va a ser menos
raíz de 2 entre 2 esto porque estamos en
radiales si estuviéramos pensando en
grados esto sería un ángulo de menos 45
grados y este es uno de los valores
trigonométricos que es bastante bueno
conocer entonces esto va a ser igual a
uno más la raíz de dos por esto por
menos la raíz de dos entre dos y
entonces esto me va a quedar igual a uno
y después observan tengo la raíz de dos
x menos la raíz de dos entre dos eso es
lo mismo que menos dos entre dos lo cual
es igual a menos uno entonces todo esto
se reduce a menos uno y ahora pensemos
qué pasa abajo tengo el coche no de
menos pri medios porque dos por menos pi
cuartos es lo mismo que menos pri medios
que si pensamos en grados serían menos
90 grados
el coseno de eso va a ser cero así que
al final terminamos con una expresión de
la forma cero entre 0 0 entre 0 y como
lo platicamos anteriormente si obtenemos
un número distinto de 0 entre 0 entonces
decimos ok eso es indefinido pero en
este caso cuando tenemos algo de la
forma 0 entre 0 significa que tienes un
límite indeterminado y eso no significa
que el límite no existe la clave aquí es
usar algunas de nuestras herramientas
que hemos construido para manipular esta
expresión y obtener una expresión que
tal vez esté definida en theta igual a
menos pi cuartos así que déjame
manipular esta expresión un poco si
tengo uno más la raíz de dos por el seno
de teta esto a su vez dividido entre el
coseno de dos teta
entonces seguramente puedes imaginar que
las cosas que nos resultarán bastante
útiles en este límite van a ser las
identidades trigonométricas esta vez en
particular vamos a fijarnos en
cosenos de dos tetas sabemos que el
coche no de dos tetas eso es lo mismo
que el coseno cuadrado de teta menos el
seno cuadrado de teta que a su vez es
igual a uno menos dos veces el seno
cuadrado de teta que por cierto también
es igual a dos veces el coseno cuadrados
de teta menos uno y puedes ir de esta a
están a están simplemente usando la
identidad pitagórica la cual hemos
probado y usado en muchísimos vídeos en
la selección de trigonometría ante la
canaca de min
ahora la pregunta sería algunas de estas
expresiones parece útil bueno observa
que estas tres son diferencias de
cuadrados así que podemos factorizar las
de diferentes formas y tal vez puedas
pensar en una forma de factorizar
algunas de estas expresiones que nos
ayude a cancelar algo para quitar este
cero entre 0 ahora si yo ahora escribo
con senos de dos teta de alguna manera
que pueda involucrar a uno más la raíz
de dos por el seno de teta
entonces
estaría muy bien y de hecho observan que
uno menos dos veces el seno cuadrado de
teta esto es exactamente lo mismo que
uno más la raíz cuadrada de dos por el
seno de teta que multiplica su vez a uno
menos la raíz cuadrada de dos por el
seno de teta así que déjame usarlo
coseno de dos tetas esto es igual a uno
menos dos veces el seno cuadrado de teta
lo cual es una diferencia de cuadrados
es decir a cuadrada más b cuadrada eso
es igual a b x a menos b y entonces me
quedaría uno más la raíz de dos por el
seno de teta que a su vez multiplica a
uno menos la raíz de dos por el seno de
teta y ahora tenemos algo que
potencialmente se puede cancelar este se
cancela con este y nos quedaría es
simplemente uno entre uno menos la raíz
de dos por el seno de teta
si quieres que estas dos expresiones
sean iguales siguiendo la idea de una
definición de función entonces tienen
que tener el mismo dominio y bueno esta
expresión ya habíamos visto que no
estaba definida para theta igual a menos
pi cuartos entonces esta nueva función
para pedirle que sea equivalente le
debemos de poner la misma restricción y
no sólo en ese valor tal vez hay otros
pero por ahora trabajaremos solamente
con la idea de que teta no puede ser
igual a menos pi cuartos y si quieres
ser muy preciso puedes pensar que sólo
estamos trabajando en un intervalo
abierto alrededor de teta igual a menos
pi cuartos sobre todo para este caso
particular es más déjame escribirlo
estamos pensando en el intervalo abierto
en el intervalo abierto se me ocurren
menos 11 y creo que ese intervalo cubre
bastante bien a menos pi cuartos porque
si tenemos por ejemplo plan pi cuartos
bueno eso no nos dará la forma 0 entre 0
aunque en pi cuartos haga este
denominador 0 pero también este otro
20 así que creo que tomarnos este
intervalo está bien tomarnos el límite
cuando te estás se aproxima algo en este
intervalo abierto y quiero ser muy
preciso porque estoy intentando explicar
esto muy bien pero obviamente si tú
estás en un examen o en tu libreta
entonces no te tomes tantos problemas no
es necesario poner todas estas
advertencias entonces lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es pensar en el límite
cuando te te atienden a menos que
cuartos de bueno esta vez 1 entre 1 - la
raíz de 2 por el seno de teta seguimos
trabajando en este intervalo abierto
pero ahora estamos en la otra
restricción ahora observa que esta
función que tengo aquí es continua y
está bien definida para theta igual a
menos pi cuartos entonces esto
simplemente será sustituir este valor en
esta función y me quedaría 1 entre 1
menos
la raíz de 2 por el seno
- para cuartos y como ya habíamos
mencionado antes el seno de menos
cuartos es lo mismo que menos raíz de 2
sobre 2 entonces esto será igual a 1
entre 1 y bueno observa que menos raíz
de 2 por menos raíz de 2 entre 2 eso es
lo mismo que menos entre menos me dio el
signo positivo y después tengo raíz de
dos por raíz de 2 esos 2 entre 2 es 1
así que esto me queda 1 entre 1 más 1 lo
cual es simplemente un medio y quiero
ser muy claro en esto esta expresión no
es la misma que esta otra expresión
podemos decir que estas dos expresiones
son iguales para todos los valores de de
tam excepto ente está igual a menos pi
cuartos ya que en ésta no está definido
y en esta sí lo están pero como hemos
visto anteriormente si encontramos una
función que es igual a la original para
todos los valores de teta excepto en
teta igual a menos pi cuartos es decir
donde la función original no está
definida en un cierto punto pero
función si lo están y además es continúa
justo ahí entonces estos dos límites
serán iguales entonces si este límite es
igual a un medio eso quiere decir que el
otro límite también será igual a un
medio y como he dicho en varios vídeos
tal vez estemos tentados a decir
manipulamos algebraica mente esto y de
alguna manera llegamos a esta expresión
y no me importan todas estas
restricciones sólo lo hago y sustituyó
el valor de teta igual a menos pi
cuartos y ya está lleva a la respuesta
pero ojo aunque esta es la respuesta
correcta es importante reconocer que
esta expresión y esta otra no son lo
mismo y entender que la razón correcta
del porqué llegamos a la respuesta es la
siguiente si tenemos dos funciones
dije iguales para todas x iguales para
todas x excepto en x iguala a am déjame
ponerlo excepto en exigua la anp y efes
continúan am eso también es muy
importante y efes continúa en am
entonces déjame escribirlo así el límite
cuando existen de a a de fx va a ser
igual al límite cuando x tiende a esa
misma a deje de x
y es justo lo que estamos diciendo aquí
y además ya tenemos que la respuesta es
un médium así que puedo decir que ya
hemos terminado